bonjour il ya de sida oui merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ariana afghan
airlines qui reprend ses vols
domestiques est ce que ça traduit en
quoi l'aéroport de kaboul est une
stratégique
c'est évidemment c'est la capitale c'est
c'est la communication c'est le contact
avec le monde entier et une cata
apparemment joue un grand rôle du
financement de l'aéroport ou peut-être
du futur gouvernement des talibans le
qatar est et c'est au qatar il ya la
plus grande base aérienne américaine qui
s il y est et j'ai lancé par le qatar a
se passe par 60% en plus l'ex ministre
des affaires étrangères qatari hamad ben
jassem al thani a déclaré dans une
interview ce sont nos alliés américains
que nous que nous nous avons demandé
qu'ils nous ont donc monté de
d'accueillir un bureau politique pour le
talibane chez nous à doha donc c'est ce
sont nos amis américains ils nous ont
demandé donc les cathares va financer et
dénonce le taliban c'est la garante que
les talibans ne va pas vers les chinois
ouvert les russes au contraire le kata
le taliban va travailler au sol de des
américains mais on l'a dit en selon le
qatar me le dire également la
réouverture de l'aéroport de kaboul va
se faire rapidement mais on l'a vu sur
les images de mourad gaz diem l'envoyait
la spéciale pour arte internationale on
en est loin pour le moment
avec l'argent avec l'argent qatari
peut-être aussi le soutien de 2 1 carat
de la turquie et la turquie est prête à
à réparer les records de kaboul je pense
qu'il ya eu des accords secrets entre
les américains et les talibans plusieurs
sources évoquent également l'annoncé
prochaine de la formation du
gouvernement des talibans a priori ce
serait demain après la prière du
vendredi d'aujourd'hui à quoi s'attendre
selon vous sachant que des femmes
afghanes par exemple ont manifesté hier
à erat pour défendre leurs droits et
appelé à la diversité
je pense les talibans ont tiré une leçon
de leur expérience amère avec al qaïda
je pense ils ont donné des signes
d'ouverture vis-à-vis d'eux si donc la
gang la regarde comme j'ai dit si le
qatar est ce pour cela peut-être vont
former un gouvernement modéré un
gouvernement peut être aussi liée des
femmes afin d'établir des liens avec
l'occident parce qu'il veut changer
l'image très très négative en occident
qui a eu lieu après les attentats du 11
septembre 2001 mais pourtant son écoute
1 le chef de la diplomatie française
jean yves le drian aucun signe de
changement de la part des talibans c'est
ce qu'il dit ce matin dans les colonnes
du figaro
le ministre des affaires étrangères
français qui dit également qu'il faudra
juger les fondamentalistes islamistes
sur leurs actes comment est-ce qu'il
faut lire entre les lignes cette sortie
de jean yves le drian
la france n'est pas l'espagne d'amérique
la france est un pays laïc très attaché
à la laïcité est elle existait entre les
forces laïques et les forces islamistes
or les américains historique - étaient
les alliés des islamistes d'ailleurs ils
ont soutenu les moujahidines afghans
contre l'union soviétique et non pas un
complexe non pas un grand problème avec
les mouvements islamistes dès que ces
mouvements ne ne représente pas une
menace contre leur référé donc la poche
agglo sexe est toujours totalement
différente peut l'approcher en plus
laïque vides habiter mouvement islamiste
les ags les années qu'elles sont
pragmatiques ils ont l expérience avec
les islamistes la même chose la grande
bretagne et d'ailleurs appelé la plupart
des mouvements islamistes de leurs pairs
le les frémissements flairé la rosa et
toujours cette opposition laïque et n'a
pas tu n'aimes pas évidemment les états
ni une question sur l'europe qui
s'inquiète d'une nouvelle vague
migratoire et qui veut éviter de
reproduire l'épisode de 2015 est ce que
l'europe on a les moyens sachant que de
nombreux évacués de kaboul 1 par les
états unis restent en europe dans les
bases américaines en attendant à un visa
pour rentrer sur le sol américain
évidemment l'europe de pâtir des
millions d'afghans mais peut-être des 10
et des milliers et c'est est clair pour
les allemands les français on va
accueillir ceux qui nous ont aidés
surtout les interprètes et traducteurs
afghane qui ont collaboré avec nos
forces avec les allié et non pas
évidemment les islamistes que ce soit
des talibans ou d'autres fractions
islamistes en afghanistan dont il ya un
tri donc les élections ils vont
accueillir pas et pas des vidéos comme
j'ai dit mais leurs amis ceux qui ont
servi les alliés en afghanistan
merci riadh sidaoui d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
un expert du monde arabe les directeurs
du quart absa à genève le centre arabe
de recherches et des analyses politiques
et sociales